did you ever wonder what would happen if
kazaro went to wano or what if Al JiJi
was appointed as a fleet Admiral instead
of a kainu or even better what would
happen if current Zorro battled mihawk
during the baretti arc well these are
all very interesting questions and after
a lot of research I am ready to answer
all of them before we can talk about
what would happen in wano if kizaru
arrived we first need to understand one
thing although kizaru is incredibly
strong he wouldn't go to the land of
Samurai alone he would most likely come
with his entire fleet including many
warships sent to Maru and even
pacifistas similar to how he recently
appeared in the Egghead island arc
considering that the regular Beast
Pirates aren't that strong sentimaru and
other soldiers should be able to easily
take care of them allowing the Admiral
to go straight to action and engage more
important targets the first people
kizaru meets would be ulti usap page one
and Nami given his personality I don't
think kizara would bother battling with
them it's more likely that he will just
ask them where their captains are as he
came here to battle strong guys while
kizaru is on his way toward Luffy and
kaido the situation in onigashima is far
more chaotic than in the original story
as there would now be three factions
fighting Marines Samurai and Beast
Pirates it would be a free-for-all
Mayhem with many casualties on all sides
kizara would eventually reach a higher
floor and finally find someone he
respects Marco the Phoenix kizarro's
appearance on this floor would add a lot
of pressure as Chopper is still trying
to figure out a cure to the only virus
that Queen had let loose on that floor
Marco would be shocked seeing kizaru
there and would immediately want to
attack him for what he did to Whitebeard
however the one who will be the voice of
reason here is Chopper who would beg
Marco not to attack him as they have
more important things to worry about now
hisaru would be disappointed but
continue climbing letting Marco know he
would return for him now depending on
when kizaru actually gets there the
situation on the rooftop can be very
different to simplify things a bit here
I'll say that kizarro will arrive in the
middle of the battle against Luffy and
kaido when everyone has already moved
from the roof at this point I think it's
likely that kazaro would play a similar
role cp0 agent played and severely
damaged Luffy from behind with one of
his laser shots you may think that Luffy
would manage to dodge a shot like this
but you need to remember that at this
point he was really tired and almost
completely out of energy even the cp0
agent in the original version managed to
surprise him so kizara would surely be
able to do the same this would enrage
kaido as he wanted to defeat Luffy by
himself he would transform into his
Dragon form and Rush towards the Admiral
kizaru and kaidu would engage in a
fierce battle that would completely
shake the whole island as all this is
happening Luffy would eventually regain
Consciousness and awaken his gear 5 form
due to his resolve to bring down kaido
he would quickly join the fight
showcasing his new abilities as he
punches kizaru away using his giant form
Admiral would begin to get overwhelmed
with both kaidu and Luffy now attacking
him they obviously didn't agree to fight
kizaru together but given the situation
they would realize that it's in their
best interest to get him out of there
before they can probably finish their
fight with this unexpected development
it's most likely that a kainu would call
Immediate Retreat of all Marines as the
situation got completely out of control
with him gone kaido and Luffy would be
able to continue their battle and Luffy
would eventually come out on top just as
in the original story looks like a kainu
was right not to let him go to wano
after all it's funny when you remember
that the only reason kizarro even came
to wano was because kaido's and big
mom's conversation was intercepted the
Emperors were literally the victims of
men in the middle attack where the
hackers can intercept your data before
it reaches its destination luckily for
the Emperors we've partnered with
nordvpn to solve their problem all they
have to do is go to nordvpn.com
jagerists and get a special deal we've
prepared for them okay in all
seriousness I use nordvpn daily for
example I like working in cafes and
using the Wi-Fi there the problem is
that public Wi-Fi's are really unsafe
and it's easy for hackers to steal my
data this is one of the main reasons I
use nordvpn as it encrypts my data at
all times making it impossible for
hackers to get it another great thing
you can use it for is bypassing geoblock
on streaming websites check this out if
I normally go on Netflix and type for
example aot there is nothing in my
search results however with nordvpn I
can just connect to Canada and there we
go I can watch aot now nor prepared a
special deal for all my subscribers and
if you download it using my link you'll
get a 30 day money back guarantee Nord
also celebrates its 11th birthday and if
you download it using my Link at
nordvpn.com jagerists you'll get an
additional mystery gift with your order
seriously guys don't be like the
Emperors download nordvpn and stay safe
online okay that last scenario was
really interesting but let's cover a bit
darker one now what would happen if
Luffy was never born what would happen
to the one piece world and other
characters well what if I tell you that
most of the straw hats would end up dead
let's go through them one by one and see
exactly what would happen if Luffy never
embarked on his journey Morgan's
tyrannical rule in shellstown would
continue and Zora would get executed
tied to a pole without ever becoming a
pirate when it comes to Nami you'd
probably think that she'll continue to
serve under our lawn but that's not
really what would happen remember the
first time Luffy and Nami met it was in
Orange town when Luffy fell from the sky
and helped her escape from Buggy's crew
since Luffy isn't there to help her in
this version it's most likely that Nami
would be captured by Pirates and
probably killed by buggy for stealing in
the syrup Village nobody would believe
usopped that Captain Kuro wants to kill
Kaya and inherit her fortune and he
would probably die trying to protect her
from Pirates the events of variety would
also change greatly with mihawk killing
Don Krieg Pirates and saving the cooks I
don't think mihawk would have any reason
to harm Sanji or the others working
there so Sanji would stay alive but
would never go out to the sea to achieve
his dream Luffy would also never visit
drum Island so waffle would probably
kill Chopper and Dr kureha for refusing
to leave his castle without losing to
stop crocodile Robin would still serve
under him in alabasta and after lying to
him about what's written on the pony
glyph he would kill her without
hesitation also without Luffy's help Jim
Bay would still be stuck in impel down
and probably be executed shortly after
Ace Brooke wouldn't be able to retrieve
his shadow on his own and would probably
be captured by ryuma and imprisoned on
Thriller bark however by far the worst
thing that would happen in this version
of the story is the world government
imprisoning Frankie and getting their
hands on blueprints for one of the
ancient weapons pluton although we still
don't know exactly what pluton is one
thing that's for sure is that it has
immense destructive capabilities and if
it falls into the government's hands no
one would ever be able to oppose them
it's also important to mention that
Luffy liberated many islands like Konomi
Islands drum island alabasta sky Pia
dressrosa and even wano without him
these islands would still be ruled by
evil Pirates and countless people would
lose their lives man if Luffy was never
born the story would be so much sadder
alright let's change the pace a bit and
cover a happier scenario next after the
events of marineford the one piece World
experienced some huge changes and one of
them was a kainu winning the duel
against our kiji and becoming the fleet
admiral of the Marines but what if that
didn't happen what if Fiji won their
duel and became the fleet Admiral with
the one-piece World be any different
well there are actually two possible
things that could happen in this
scenario without kgs Fleet Admiral the
first thing he would do is appoint Garth
as his closest Ally I think this is
likely to happen because they share
similar views on Justice and GARP was
the one who trained aokiji when he
joined the Marines next just as aokiji
left in the original story I think
Akainu would leave Marines in this
version kokichi and Akainu are two sides
of the same coin they both want justice
but have completely different ways of
achieving it and therefore I don't think
either one could stand serving under the
other of course I don't think akinu
would join Blackbeard Pirates like
aokiji did he would instead probably
create a small Alliance of his own and
fight the Pirates similar to what Zephyr
did in Film Z okay with a kainu leaving
and aokiji in charge the things in one
piece world are bound to get better
right right well not so much the thing
about the world government and how it
operates is that the fleet Admiral
doesn't have the freedom to make any
change they want it's also important to
remember that they report directly to
the five elders and no matter how good
their intentions are they can't do
anything major without their approval if
akiji really wanted to make a change he
would need to trick them by doing what
they asked him to do but making secret
plans with his trusted team in the
shadows this team would consist of
Marines who share his ideals and moral
compass some people that come to mind
are GARP smoker shiggy Kobe helmeppo
Tina and maybe even fujitora aokiji
would directly command this group
sending them Undercover on the islands
to stop dangerous criminals that the
world government doesn't care about one
of the main criminals they would go
after is doflamingo and they would
probably manage to get rid of him even
before Luffy comes to dress Rosa this
all sounds pretty good but there is a
much darker path this scenario can take
okay let's go back to the beginning one
thing that I want to remind you of is
that many important people from the
world government maybe even some
Celestial dragons want wanted a kainu to
be in charge this is possibly because He
follows the absolute Justice and would
be easier to control whatever the case I
don't think these powerful people would
just watch how kiji become a fleet
Admiral and jeopardize the government
this is why they would most likely try
to kill and replace him with someone
they can trust if they would actually
manage to do something like this isn't
really clear but if someone dangerous
like Kong five Elders or even emu likes
this plan it shouldn't be too hard to
permanently get rid of aokiji if this
actually happened it would be really bad
as Not only would the Marines be run by
someone evil but one of the good guys
would also be dead I definitely wouldn't
want this scenario to happen however the
one scenario I know all of us would like
to see is what would happen if current
post juano Zorro battled mihawk during
the beretti arc zoro's encounter with
mihawk at beretti was one he was
definitely not prepared for at that
point in the story Zoro was very naive
thinking he was strong without even
knowing essential abilities like hockey
he was quickly humiliated by mihawk
which made him realize just how weak he
really is however since then over 1 1000
chapters have passed and with each one
Zorro keeps getting stronger and
stronger so what if current Sora with
all his current abilities and Powers was
fighting mihawk at beretti what would
happen in this scenario and who would
win okay so the battle would start out
the same with mihawk arriving in zuro
challenging him to a duel this time
around mihawk would be able to sense
that his opponent is really strong and
would therefore take the battle more
seriously in the original story he
pulled out a small knife hidden in his
necklace however this time he would
immediately pull out Euro his Supreme
grade sword miak would show respect to
Zorro acknowledging him as a worthwhile
opponent and would ask for his name
after azoro gives it mihawk says Bring
It On rora Noah fight me zoru would
angrily Rush towards him attacking him
with his two sword style which mihawk
easily repels is that all you got rora
Noah Zoro would smile and draw it and my
his third sword he proceed to use his
Advanced conquerors hockey and Infuse it
with it the two with it start attacking
each other again with their Clash
causing the sky to split into similar to
in kaido and big mom fought every at the
restaurant would turn their attention to
the fight not believing what they were
seeing I mean just imagine Luffy seeing
power like this at that point his
expression would be ridiculous anyway
Zoro would continue to attack using the
techniques like Foxfire style and even
Ashura and mihawk would keep defending
without taking much damage as the fight
progresses mihawk shows greater skill
and composure while zoro's struggles but
continues to attack him with everything
he's got frustrated Zoro would prepare
his final attack that he used to defeat
King 103 Mercy's Dragon damn nation in
response mihawk would prepare his
strongest attack which
well
it doesn't really have a name since
mihawk doesn't name his attacks but it
will surely be incredibly strong anyway
the two Swordsmen clash with everything
they have and as the dust clears mihawk
is standing while Zorro is defeated on
the floor at that point I don't think
mihawk would kill Zorro he likes to have
a rival and it's more likely that he
will encourage Zorro to get even
stronger and find him again click on
this video where we explained what would
happen if kaido arrived at Marine 4
during the summit War